find the least common multiple of 15 X
20 and x squared plus 5x so when you're
trying to find the least common multiple
of a bunch of numbers you want to break
them down into their smallest
constituent parts and if you're dealing
with regular numbers non variables
though smallest constituent parts are
the prime factorization of those numbers
and if you're dealing with things that
have variable expressions you just want
to factor them into their simplest
possible components you can't really
call those prime factorizations so let's
try to do it and once you do that the
least common multiple just needs to be
the smallest number that can be factored
into those constituents and just has
those constituents in them so let's
factor each of them so if i factor 15 x
this is the same thing as let's factor
this is the same thing as 15 times X +
15 we could do a prime factorization
here 15 is 3 times 5 both 3 & 5 are
prime so we can factor this as 3 times 5
times X that's the the well before the
coefficient we've done the prime
factorization and then X that's as much
as we can factor we can break it down we
don't know if X is necessary prime or
not it's a variable let's do the same
thing for 20 so 20 here can be factored
into 2 and 10 and 10 can be factored
into 2 & 5 so 20 is equal to 2 times 2
times 5 and that's just a straight-up
prime factorization now let's do x
squared + 5 X x squared + 5 X we can
factor out an X both of these terms are
divisible by X so this is equal to x
times X plus 5 right if you divide if
you factor out an X here you just get an
X if you factor out an X out of 5 X you
just get a 5 and so the least common
multiple so let me write it down the
least common multiple the least common
multiple has to have the smallest number
that has all of these components at
least so it has all of these factors in
it so let's just start with the smallest
numbers and then we'll get to the
variables
so it has to have at least two tubes
because we have tutus here we don't have
any of them here but it has to have at
least two twos so you have to let me do
it in those pink twos so it has to have
at least two twos two times two if it's
going to be divisible by twenty it's
also going to need a five we'll get to
that in a second so it needs to have at
least two twos and then it needs to have
at least one three and needs at least
one three if it has any chance of being
divisible by 15 X so it has to have at
least one three none of these guys so at
least one three and then five if it has
any chance of being divisible by 15 X it
has to have at least one five if it has
any chance of being divisible by 20 it
has to have at least one five so it has
to have at least one five this one five
right over here will help make ensure
that it's divisible by both 15 X and 20
although we haven't put all of the
factors there although this is already
divisible by 20 because you have the two
times two times five here this isn't
quite divisible by 15 X yet because we
don't have an X here it is divisible
already by 15 because you already have
the three times the five you already
have the three times the five here and
then you get to that X this tert this
right over here has one x value so in
order to be divisible by 15 X it has to
have at least one X here and so this is
already divisible by 15 X you actually
have 15 X right over here 3 times 5
times X it's already divisible by 20 you
have 2 times 2 times 5 that is 20 is it
divisible by X squared plus 5 X well it
does have this X here but it still
doesn't have an X plus 5 in it it still
doesn't have an X plus 5 so let me do
that in orange so this the least common
multiple also needs also needs and X
plus 5 over here and so this is the
least common multiple if you want to
multiply it out to maybe simplify it a
little bit 2 times 2 is 4 4 times 3 is
12 12 times 5 12 times 5 is 60 60 times
X is 60 X so this is 60 X 60 x times X
plus 5 and we can if we want multiply it
out 60 X
X plus 5 is 60 x-squared I'm just
distributing the 60 X 60 x squared plus
60 times 5 is 300 300 X and there you go
the least common multiple